you're a father of 10 children
ages 2 to 31 and a grandbaby
a year and a half what is it about
being a father i'm not not even that you
love
how did the experience
of becoming a father
multiple times change you as a man
as a human wow that's too much to say
well just give me a little bit of that
yeah i will say that uh
uh my children are the center of of
of my life and uh having children
having family it keeps you grounded and
uh centered but if you put your children
first
with before you make any decision
you never make a bad decision hmm that
would be brilliant
brilliant you never make one bad
decision if you put them first
so is that what you were doing those
years you were resting on the couch is
that what you were doing that's what
happened that's what i've been doing
since
that's what i've been doing since i've
had them putting like putting them first
they've been first
you know at first somebody said to me
i was talking some to somebody last week
and they were like
they was like oh so this movie they're
coming to america and this is your
legacy
and with your legacy and i was like my
legacy but like my legacy is not
movies my legacy is my children not my
my movies
when i die ain't nobody gonna be at my
funeral standing over the cough and
going
then first you did 48 hours then he
moved on to trading places
and then he did the great beverly hills
cop let's show a clip
you